ça y est ici à vélizy 2 il faut
désormais présenter un qr code à
l'entrée pour pouvoir faire ses
emplettes une seule exception à la règle
si vous venez pour vous faire vacciner
ou pour vous faire tester ici toutes les
entrées sont soumises aux passes
sanitaires et la mesure ne plaît pas à
tout le monde dès notre arrivée une
femme s'insurge contre le dispositif
pour l'entreprise qui gère le centre
commercial l'investissement pour
appliquer la règle est conséquent
dix-sept employés de sécurité
supplémentaires en semaine 23 le samedi
pour un coût d'environ 120 mille euros
par mois les denrées alimentaires sont
elles aussi concernées le supermarché
présents dans le centre commercial
contrôler le pass sanitaires à l'entrée
et pour les personnes qui ne peuvent
plus entrer une solution est possible
sur place nous on n'en mesure aussi
d'accompagner les gens qui sont
mécontents alors dix ans qui a un centre
de vaccination à wasyl vélizy 2 on
vaccine depuis le mois de juin à peu
près 1000 personnes par jour à côté de
la pharmacie et à côté de ça pour les
personnes qui n'auraient pas de pass and
i ter ont aussi un centre de test
antigénique et on a déjà réalisé vingt
mille tests depuis le mois de novembre
nous on estime que l'application de ce
pays ce pas sanitaire est injuste et
crée une distorsion de la concurrence
par rapport aux autres enseignes on
n'est que 5 % de l'offre commerciale en
france nous les grands centres
commerciaux
si c'est efficace on alpiq partout où
nulle part voilà avant l'entrée en
vigueur de la mesure les avis étaient
partagés à l'entrée de l'un des centres
commerciaux concernés ça va gêner tout
le monde est parce qu il ya d autres qui
sont pas encore faits les vaccins
donc du coup ils pourront pas rentrer et
les commerçants ça va se trouver qu'ils
auront pu des clients ils vont se
trouver en crise je trouve ça très bien
que le passé à lithaire soit plutôt
obligatoire et sécurisé ce qu'ils ont
globalement c'est une bonne chose et
j'estime que c'est ce sont des atteintes
aux libertés individuelles donc non mais
bon dans un pays où on
on ne décide pas tout c'est comme ça il
ya des règles du jeu on vient en
collectivité et c'est une pandémie
mondiale donc on fait face or les
problèmes de conscience de certains
devant ces mesures il est dit c'est
aussi vers les pertes de chiffre
d'affaires que les inquiétudes se
portent le gouvernement lui ne montre
aucune intention de lever le pied sur
ses mesures controversées focalisant son
attention sur son objectif de 50
millions de primo vacciner avant la
rentrée la rentrée où les opposants pas
sanitaire espère mobiliser en masse pour
contrer les plans de l'exécutif